[Music]
well
welcome to how the light gets in and to
this debate
the key to progress science was the
vehicle of progress and the
solution to the world's ills the bedrock
of the philosophy of the modern west
um but the halo of science has somewhat
slipped
and science is now seen by some at least
as potentially a malevolent force um
a tool of the military industrial
complex a damaging exploiter of natural
resources
um an ideology masquerading as a single
source of objective truth
um should we welcome this shift in our
perception of science as the end of a
unquestioning and naive belief in a
false god
or is it a a dangerous and potentially
disastrous slide into prejudice and
superstition
that will in the end leave us all poorer
less safe and less in control of our
lives
to help us discuss this i have um
three speakers we have henry
g he's a recovering paleontologist
evolutionary biologist
science fiction writer and is currently
the senior editor of nature the
international acclaimed science magazine
we also have ganesh taylor she's a
scientist at the francis crick institute
where her research is predominantly
focused on the genetic formation of
ovaries and testes
and does most of her work on chickens
and philip gough
he's a philosopher of consciousness at
durham university
a stern critic of materialism and a
defender of the
um once rather exotic and now
increasingly
interesting pan psychism so
should we question the dominance of
science and its ability to solve all the
world's ills
henry would you would you start us off
sure
science is not magic
or any way strange or inaccessible
really it's just the formal
application of common sense to
um the phenomena one sees in the world
um lately though and i mean lately in
certainly since i've been at nature in
the past 30 years ago
that 30 years or so there has been a
problem in which
um science is both revered
by the public people in white coats
mostly men are seen as kind of like
gandalf
they have occult knowledge that they can
um
impart to the world but on the other
side other hand
because of this kind of priestly quality
uh science are scientists are seen as
suspicious or even feared
um the committee of the public
understanding of science
set up by the royal society oodles of
years ago
tried to um rectify this
and i think they um missed trick
they proposed a top-down approach
in which the public was uh the great
unwashed public
had to receive as if from on high the
facts that you the public
should know without question and of
course that only
reinforced the idea that um
scientists were of some inaccessible uh
god-like
status when really science actually
begins
in childhood as naive curiosity
what happens if i poke something with
this big stick or not
so science should come from beneath um
it shouldn't be
dictated as a top-down uh
activity um so really i think the the
solution to this is science
should present itself as entirely humble
before the evidence
science does not have all the answers
we scientists invite you to participate
in helping us
understand the world a little bit more
than we do and
that any any fool anybody
any child is perfectly entitled to ask a
question
there is no such thing as a silly
question there is no such thing as
authority um and i think once science
is or has a more humble open approach i
think this dichotomy that we have seen
in which you alluded to
um will probably fade away but the
scientists themselves
uh you know richard dawkins the public
understanding of science
that strain has not done itself any
favors thank you henry finished
i would suggest that to question
is part of the scientific method and
therefore everybody should always
question the dominance of science
and also question its ability to solve
the world's ills
however i would suggest that the
scientific method is about posing a
question
looking for evidence um finding an
answer
for which you believe at least most of
the evidence um
is in keeping in this case i would
suggest that
science um is just a vehicle so
does it innately make life worse
absolutely not
um i think that it is a tool that we use
to do with
which as we see fit and so
i would say that um the top-down
approach that henry alluded to
is actually um the reason why society
might have gotten a little bit
frustrated with science
because a top-down approach of
delivering facts
implies somehow that facts are fixed
the word fact in fact does that doesn't
it um whereas in fact
what what a scientist says when they
make a statement is
judging from the evidence that we've
assessed this is very very likely to be
the outcome that we
uh you know think
is is the answer to the question that we
had so
um what i'm basically trying to say is i
think people should actually adopt the
scientific method more
in their lives and that it is absolutely
viable for everybody and should be
encouraged um
to to everyone and i think calling it
the scientific method actually can be
quite alienating
um so exactly as henry says it's just
common sense it's just a way of thinking
about things
um and i i think that
you know i think that we need to as
human beings
take a little bit of responsibility for
what we've done and
and and rather than looking at science
and going well terrible things have
happened to the world and
the climate is being ruined by science
and all that sort of thing maybe you
think
science doesn't do things on its own
that's not how it works humans do things
with human knowledge
humans uncover knowledge because they
want to find answers to things and
solutions to problems and uh i think
that we should maybe
consider carefully which which questions
we would like
to uh you know focus our human minds and
the
sort of scientific method on to that's
what i'd say
thank you phillip over to you
yeah so i think the success of science
over the over the last 400 years has
is truly mind-blowing both in terms of
its
capacity to explain so much of the
universe we live in
and also in terms of the incredible
technology it's produced that has
transformed the planet we live on but
what lesson should we draw from that
success
one very common reaction is scientism
so according to scientism what we should
learn from this great success
is that science is the only path to
knowledge the only
source of truth and everything else is
just superstitious nonsense
i draw a slightly different lesson from
this
i believe that the reason science has
been so successful
is because since galileo it's focused
on a quite narrow focused task roughly
accounting for publicly observable data
and it's excelled in that task the
problem is
however i think there are things we know
to be real
which are not known on the basis of
public observation and i'll give you two
quick examples
the first is consciousness consciousness
is not
publicly observable you can't look
inside somebody's
head and see their feelings and
experiences
uh you know the consciousness is known
about not on the basis of observation
and experiment
but on the basis of our immediate
awareness of our own
feelings and experiences so this is
something we know to be real
but is not known about on the basis of
observation
and experiment the philosopher daniel
dennett is wonderfully consistent on
this this is why he doesn't believe in
consciousness
second example are the entities
mathematicians deal with abstract
objects like numbers
sets mathematical functions these
abstract objects
have no place in the spatiotemporal
realm the science studies they are
eternal timeless objects they're known
about not through observation experiment
but through
mathematical intuition so again we've
got some entities that
we know to be real i would argue but are
not known about
on the basis of observation and
experiment
i think we're currently going for a
phase of history
that will be looked back upon as a time
when we were quite understandably
completely blown away by the success of
physical science
but i think that's led us to forget
about the importance of philosophy
the job of philosophy in my view is to
bring together
what we know from science from
observation experiment
but also things we know about in other
ways consciousness
abstract objects and to synthesize this
together
in a single unified world view so
science is wonderful
we should all have respect for it but
it's not the full story
thank you and which rather neatly brings
us i suppose to
to the first sort of topic to continue
watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas